it's an historic milestone no president
wants to reach Democrats have begun
drafting articles of impeachment against
Donald Trump
so is he worried but the woman leading
the charge says Democrats are compelled
and convinced by what they've heard the
facts are uncontested the president
abused his power for his own personal
political benefit the president leaves
us no choice but to act it comes at a
cost per division so where next a
Christmas and a New Year dominated by
process and partisanship the House is
expected to vote to impeach the
president Democrats only need a simple
majority
and there are 233 of them compared to
197 Republicans that certainly doesn't
mean he's removed from the White House
though the next step is a trial in the
Senate which is currently controlled by
Republicans 53 compared to 45 on the
other side
two-thirds of senators would need to
find the president guilty for him to be
removed from office that is highly
unlikely Donald Trump may well relish a
chance to pick his own witnesses now he
could be cleared by the Senate by
February and straight on to the campaign
trail he may well use this all as a
rallying cry impeachment isn't top of
most voters priority lists in a country
pretty tired of political investigations
an impeachment is a stain on a
president's legacy but not always the
end Donald Trump just needs to convince
enough people they shouldn't believe
or care about the charges Cordelia Lynch
Sky News Washington